based on DC's Hellblazer series the 2005
comic-book flick Constantine became an
unlikely cult favorite despite changing
just about everything from the source
material in order to fit star Keanu
Reeves yet despite its popularity
there's still no sign of a second
installment of the franchise here's a
look at why we never got to see a
Constantine sequel jana reeves wasn't
interested after the original film was
released director francis lawrence said
that he wanted to do a sequel and
following the success of his 2007 hit I
am Legend he had the clout to make it
happen just one problem
Reeves didn't want to do any sequels
ever because he said he hadn't played
any parts interesting enough to revisit
this part since then he's changed his
tune stating in the 2014 read it asked
me anything session that I love
Constantine - I love playing John
Constantine I wish there was a sequel
with me in it
now you tell us it wasn't a hit most
comic book movies seem to fall into one
of two categories gigantic mega
blockbusters like The Avengers or a
complete box office disasters like Green
Lantern I know right but Constantine
fell into the middle ground earning 230
million worldwide against a 100 million
dollar budget that's a decent return but
not spectacular enough to ensure a
sequel would get made especially since
the franchise's are rating effectively
ruled out the teenagers who usually make
up the target audience for comic book
films sure if Constantine had done
Deadpool numbers a sequel would have
gotten the green light on opening
weekend but it didn't hey guys let's get
out there and make a difference you know
what to do
the pitch got tossed constantine
director francis lawrence had tried a
few times to get a sequel off the ground
using a script called through the eye of
the needle by the screenwriter of the
original film frank a cappella a plan
for the sequel which reportedly was
based on an original idea rather than a
story from the comics supposed to do a
smaller film with a 35 million dollar
budget and make it a hard-r which sounds
pretty awesome for a movie about an
occult detective fresh thinking
unfortunately the suits didn't find it
as interesting as lawrence and the
studio passed maybe it was all just a
test it's only in the face of horror
that you truly find you'll notice l.a
Constantine TV show flopped after plan
to the sequel went nowhere Warner
Brothers decided to go a different
direction with the property result a
Constantine TV series which debuted on
NBC in 2014
starring matt ryan the show took a
somewhat more faithful approach to the
character but it was still cancelled
after just 13 episodes the character has
since appeared in a guest role on the
CW's arrow so even though the show is no
longer around the existence of a
competing version of the properties film
muddies the waters for any possible film
sequel it may be rebooted one of the
most exciting projects in the DC
Cinematic Universe is the proposed
Justice League dark movie which features
John Constantine as part of a group of
supernatural types who tackle mystical
threats the regular Justice League isn't
equipped to handle that opens a big can
of worms in terms of Constantine - sure
Reeves might be up for a sequel but what
he wanted to play the character is part
of an ensemble superhero movie if not
it's very possible the character will be
recast making a reboot more likely than
the sequel sure Constantine was able to
defeat Satan but there's one thing even
he can't beat Hollywood
thanks for watching click the looper
icon subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]